allí es chófer de taxi y desde el inicio
de la crisis de la gasolina pasa la
mitad de su jornada laboral haciendo
largas colas como esta
estoy esperando me toca esperar dos
veces al día pasó una hora o una hora y
media haciendo cola y a veces justo
cuando me toca ya no queda gasolina en
la estación
el combustible no solo es difícil de
encontrar sus precios también se han
disparado el estado al borde de la
quiebra debió reducir las subvenciones
para la compra de este producto
la bencina se importa hoy a un cambio de
3 mil 900 libras por dólar en lugar de
1500 una medida que preocupa al i
ayer gasté 100.000 libras para llenar el
tanque en todo el día invertí 150.000
libras entonces solamente obtuve 50.000
libras de ganancia
hoy gaste 65 mil libras en combustible
lo que quiere decir que estoy perdiendo
dinero tengo cuatro niños que alimentar
y no sé cómo hacerlo
pero la escasez de combustible afecta
también otros aspectos de la vida
cotidiana
el problema no es solamente llenar el
tanque sino que es más grande y va a
afectar también las hospitalizaciones el
turismo y toda la economía
todos los productos van a ser más caros
es debido al coste del transporte
por transportation porque para llevar un
producto de un lado a otro necesitamos
gasolina
esta crisis dentro de la crisis afecta
gravemente el estado de ánimo de la
población más que nunca los libaneses
temen que el país no pueda sobreponerse
de este golpe